apex legends emergence is right around
the corner season 10 of respawns battle
royale introduces a new playable legend
in the form of seer
makes substantial changes to world's
edge and implements major balance and
changes to several weapons and
characters
over the course of this video we'll go
through everything you need to know
including the new law and abilities for
seer info on the three maps coming to
arenas
the rampage lmg and the return of the
disrupter ammo
first up when can we expect to play apex
legends emergence well you won't have to
wait long it's scheduled to begin on
august the 3rd
which follows the conclusion of the
limited time thrill seekers event as it
stands respawn hasn't yet released the
patch notes for the emergence update
but if the studio sticks to the pattern
of past seasons though we can expect to
get them the day before the new season
starts
which would be obviously august 2nd
season 10 introduces apex legends 18th
playable character
obi aka sia sia is a recon character and
his ability kit makes him more of a
tracker like bloodhound than the more
scout-like pathfinder crypto and
valkyrie
he is geared towards hunting down enemy
squads in close quarters
in terms of sears abilities his passive
is heartseeker the skill
allows sia to hear the heartbeat of
enemy legends while aiming down sights
which naturally helps them discover
their location his tactical ability is
focus of attention which gives seer the
ability to release several mini drones
and after a short delay they can mark
all enemies in front of him
interrupting their use of healing items
and revives and revealing vital
information like their location and
health to see and his allies
for eight seconds lastly his ultimate
ability is exhibit
which has sia throw out his heart
chamber which releases hundreds of mini
drones that form a sphere
enemies that move too quickly or fire
the weapons in the sphere become marked
revealing their location to see and his
allies enemies can destroy sierra's
heart chamber by shooting it
in a similar manner to stopping crypto
and horizon's ultimate abilities
in terms of law sierra has a complicated
history one informed by an old
folk tale called the moth and the flame
the folk tale foretells a prophecy that
a cursed moth will be reborn as a human
child
a child who will blindly lead humanity
to its destruction
azir was born with glowing eyes and to a
mother with a moth tattoo and on a day
when a fiery meteor destroyed his
planet's moon
those around him in his community
believed him to be this foretold
cursed child he was shunned but his
father taught him how to command
a fleet of minidrones and his mother
gifted him with dance and an
appreciation for art
sia took their lessons and developed a
mesmerizingly elegant but brutal
fighting style
that combined the two earning him nine
years of accolades in the underground
arenas
his fame got him a place in the new apex
games
emergence introduces a number of buffs
and nerfs to existing legends too
first up caustic receives a buff which
sees his gas damage increase
every other second with no limit on how
much it can increase and the gas cloud
created from caustics knox gas grenade
dissipates five seconds sooner
horizon also sees a buff which sees her
gravity lift maneuver adjusted to be
closer to how it was in season seven
lastly on the buff side of things fuse's
knuckle cluster move
will now last twice as long allowing him
to deny areas for longer and then
enemies caught in the mother lode will
be highlighted making it easier for fuse
and his allies to plan their follow-up
attack
on the nerve side of things enemies will
now get an audible and visual indication
when death totem's death protection is
about to end
letting them know that revenant and his
allies are about to be vulnerable
hammond's continued efforts to mine
talos for its natural resources will
decimate world's edge at the start of
emergence
the lava crack caused by the harvester
lengthens and the destruction extends to
touch both the southern and northern
parts of the map
sorting factory is completely destroyed
falling into a sinkhole
this landmark will be replaced by a new
point of interest lava siphon
the destruction causes a landslide to
the nearby mountains burying train yard
and debris
and transforming it into the new poi
called landslide
most of the changes can be seen in the
north refinery will be completely wiped
out replaced by climatizer a
significantly larger point of interest
nearby a new lava crack is opened up
though it won't provide a heated updraft
like the one that cuts through the
middle of world's edge
and though it's not a point of interest
a new giant dam will be constructed
between climatizer and epicenter
to prevent the lava from spilling into
the rest of world's edge at both
climatizer and lava siphon
moving gondolas will be added to the map
providing movable cover for squads in a
similar capacity to the train
that once moved through world's edge in
seasons three to five
during season 10 the arenas maps based
on existing kings canyon world's edge
and olympus landmarks
are being rotated out so no more playing
arenas and artillery thermal station
gardens
in their place three new landmark based
arenas are rotating in king's canyon's
hillside
world's edges dome and olympus's oasis
these three maps will exist in the
arena's playlist rotation alongside
phase runner party crasher
and overflow emergence adds the rampage
to ground loop
a brand new heavy ammo lmg the rampage
sets itself apart from any other lmg by
being slower but more powerful variation
of the spitfire
making it an ideal mid-range weapon
similar to the weapons like the 30 30
repeater and bosek compound bow the
rampage doesn't fire fast enough to be
much of a threat at close range
and similar to the sentinel sniper rifle
the rampage can be charged but instead
of using shield cells the rampage takes
through my grenades once charged the
rampage fires much
more quickly making it a decent close
range threat
and allowing it to also easily destroy
doors similar to grenades
at the start of emergence the prowler
will rotate out the care packages and
once again become a ground loop weapon
however the gun will only have a burst
fire mode and you won't be able to
switch it to automatic fire in its place
both the spitfire and alternator are
rotating into care packages
in care packages the spitfire will
revert to its pre-nerfed state and the
alternator will automatically come
equipped with disrupter rounds
because of these care package
adjustments in arenas you'll be able to
buy the prowler and no longer be able to
purchase the alternator or spitfire in
terms of hop-ups both the anvil receiver
and quick draw will be removed from the
game at the start of emergence
the traits of quick draw will
automatically be implemented into
pistols
though to a lesser degree in their place
apex legends is getting a brand new
hop-up
the boosted loader this hop-up goes on
the hemlock and wingman changing the
guns so that they reload faster
and get bonus ammo if reloaded at the
right time similar to deadeye's tempo
it's a timing based hop-up emergence
will also change the l-star
the lmg will now also take barrel
stabilizers and extended energy
magazines
high level energy mags will increase the
time it takes for the l-star to overheat
and cause it to cool faster when it does
and speaking of speed the fire rates for
the eva 8 when it has
shotgun bolts equipped is being nerfed
additionally reload speed will also no
longer
be tied to extended magazines starting
in season 10.
instead that trait will now be tied to
the standard stocks and sniper stocks
and speaking of sniper stocks marksman
rifles will start taking
sniper stocks in season 10 as opposed to
the standard ones
ranked arenas is also coming to apex
legends in season 10.
these arenas will exist on a wholly
separate playlist
when season 10 starts you'll have to
play 10 ranked arenas matches to figure
out where you'll be placed
there is also no penalty to ranked
arenas at the higher ranks
you don't earn points based on how many
kills and assists you get either
you simply gain points for winning and
losing points for losing
the arena's rank will exist separately
to your battle royale rank
like previous seasons emergence adds a
new battle pass that includes over 100
cosmetic rewards
including two legendary character skins
and two legendary reactive weapon skins
this time around valkyrie and horizon
are getting the new legendary character
skins and the volt smg is getting the
legendary reactive weapon skin
and that is it if you're a fan of apex
legends make sure to like the video
and to subscribe to the channel for more
apex legends emergence
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you